el perímetro de una cerca rectangular
mide 0.72 kilómetros la longitud del
área encerrada es de 160 metros 160
metros cual es el ancho bueno vamos a
hacer un dibujo para entender mejor este
problema nos dicen que tenemos una cerca
rectangular entonces tenemos un área de
este estilo y nos dicen que el perímetro
es 0.72 kilómetros eso lo que nos dice
es que si recorremos esta cerca
alrededor
en total recorremos 0.72 kilómetros esta
longitud más ésta más esta más esta es
0.72 kilómetros ok además nos dicen que
la longitud del área encerrada es de 160
metros déjame pensar que este lado de
acá es la longitud voy a tomar la
herramienta de lápiz entonces estoy acá
va a ser la longitud y nos dicen que
mide que mide 160 metros como esto es un
rectángulo también este lado de acá mide
160 metros
160 metros y lo que nos preguntan lo que
queremos determinar es cuál es el ancho
de esta de esta área rectangular bueno
el ancho lo voy a poner en color rosa y
lo que nos están preguntando es cuál es
esta longitud esta longitud de acá o sea
cuál es cuánto mide el ancho déjame
ponerle que mide a metros y lo que
tenemos que hacer es determinar el valor
de a a metros como esto mide a y este es
un rectángulo de este lado también
tenemos que mide a que mide a metros
metros muy bien ahora cómo podemos
utilizar la información de que el
perímetro es cierta cantidad pues como
te dije el perímetro es sumar todas
estas longitudes así que vamos a
escribir eso aquí abajo tenemos que el
perímetro
el perímetro de metro
es igual a la suma de estas cuatro
longitudes a metros
metros más 160 metros 160 metros más a
metros
metros más 160 metros 160 metros muy
bien y como todas estas unidades están
en metros eso es importante como todas
están en metros podemos sumar las y
obtener lo siguiente obtener que el
perímetro es igual a lo voy a poner aquí
entre paréntesis a más a es 2 a 2 a más
160 160 es 320 más 320 metros metros
pudimos hacer la suma porque todas
estaban en metros ahora lo que nos
gustaría hacer es utilizar esta
información de que el perímetro también
es 0.72 kilómetros no voy a poner aquí
abajo el perímetro el perímetro
también es igual a 0.72 km entonces
sería fantástico que pudiéramos igualar
esta expresión con esta de acá sin
embargo la expresión de aquí abajo está
en kilómetros y la de aquí en metros y
para igualarlas necesitamos necesitamos
que estén en las mismas unidades así que
déjame convertir estos cero puntos 72
kilómetros a metros entonces para poder
cancelar estas unidades de kilómetros
deben aparecer en el denominador
kilómetros y para que aparezcan metros
debe aparecer la unidad en el numerador
y ahora debemos escribir cuántos metros
hay en cada kilómetro y hay mil verdad
el prefijo kilo significa mil debe de
modo que hay mil metros por cada
kilómetro muy bien entonces hay que
multiplicar este número por mil eso es
igual a eso es igual a como le podemos
hacer para hacer esta multiplicación
bueno pues podemos hacer mil por 72 los
que nos quedaría 72
con tres ceros pero luego aquí hay un
punto decimal que se recorre dos veces
verdad una dos entonces aquí tendría que
ir dos hacia la izquierda una 2 720 de
esta forma a 0.72 km es 720 metros y eso
tiene sentido verdad 720 es como tres
cuartas partes de mil y 0.72 es como
tres cuartas partes de uno bueno
entonces ya tenemos el perímetro
expresado en metros con esto podemos
igualar estas dos expresiones tenemos
que 720 700 720 es igual a 2 a más 320
es más déjame ponerlo aquí metros
para para que de veras estemos igualando
el perímetro entonces eso es igual a 2 a
más voy a poner aquí el paréntesis 320
320 metros y ahora sí a partir de esta
ecuación podemos igualar la cantidad de
metros ya no sólo el perímetro entonces
podemos hacer que 720 podemos poner que
720 lo voy a hacer de este lado 700
720 es igual a 2 a más 320 2 a más 320 y
nos gustaría encontrar el valor de a así
que déjame restar 320 de ambos lados
para dejar a él solito aquí a la
izquierda o bueno simplemente acompañado
por un coeficiente restamos 320 restamos
320 de este lado se cancela justo de ser
el chiste y aquí queda 720 menos 320 o
sea 400 nos queda que 400 es igual a 2 y
aquí restamos de ambos lados 320 porque
teníamos una igualdad y para preservarla
había que hacer lo mismo en ambos lados
de la igualdad verdad bueno tenemos que
400 es igual a 2a y ahora podemos
dividir entre 2 a ambos lados de esta
igualdad entre 2 y aquí también entre 2
el 2 se cancela con el 2 y nos queda que
a
es igual a 200 200 de esta forma como a
es 200 a tomar el color amarillo
tenemos que esta longitud de acá es 200
200 metros muy bien y si lo piensas
tiene sentido esto es 200 metros y estoy
acá también es 200 metros
200 metros y 200 metros son 400 y 320
son 720 de modo que el perímetro es 720
metros y eso concuerda con lo que nos
decían porque 720 metros
es lo mismo que 0.72 km